trash taste is coming to Europe if you
guys have seen before we've announced
that we are doing a Europe tour in
September of 2023 tickets are still
available for some of the shows so get
them while they are there links down in
the description below so we hope you
enjoy and if you want to see us in
person well looking forward to seeing
you guys in Europe how many Final
Fantasy games have you played I have
finished zero Final Fantasy games I've
started ff7 remake haven't finished that
we have a problem you realize that right
finish a goddamn game
foreign
I last night I ordered Thai food and I
ordered Thai food from this place sounds
like an AI conversation yes yes okay so
this I am judging you have my attention
Connor you I know you like Thai food
yeah it's a Thai man and I I had two
Thai places that I like to order from
one of them does like just the best
green curry it's just great it's a
perfect spice level the other one they
have Thai sausage which if you've never
had it it's amazing try it it's so good
yeah does it taste as much like sausage
in my mind as other stuff but it's just
filled with an ungodly amount of spice
yeah spices and they do that but the
green curry isn't as good yeah so I'm
like oh [__] so this time I ordered from
that place with the Thai sausage I'm
kind of craving the sausage
and uh I I leave a note saying hey okay
last time you gave me this uh green
curry there was no spice to it yeah you
add spice please yeah
um and they did and they added a lot so
you're leaning out of your ass today has
been a rough day for me yes I I think
they definitely I I literally I put I
translated into Japanese I said can you
please make it spicy last time it wasn't
uh and I think I should take that as an
insult the chef I didn't want to be that
guy I tried to frame it not like an
insult but that it would it would
definitely catch their attention to be
like oh this [__] guy fine because I
wanted the spice level to be insane yeah
I was not expecting the jump but did
they added it was like it went from like
no spice whatsoever for Japanese people
to just automatically extreme tie
difficulty it was like it was spicy for
even Thai it was crazy I I think it was
the uh you know if I were to see that
note
um it's the it wasn't spicy enough last
time yeah last time it wasn't yeah yeah
the only reason I thought to do this
because you did this one time as well
but you wrote it in Thai right yeah you
were like hey please make it spicy I'm
Thai don't worry I'm tired don't worry
I'm tired yeah well that's the thing
because
that's where I wrote it last time as
well and they just completely ignored me
right I just ride it entirely yeah I
wrote it in Japanese that's why yeah and
better this time around Japanese too
yeah they listened oh my god well they
took it as a challenge I think they took
it yeah I think they literally were like
let's kill this man and I ate it all
it's great uh it was very spicy there I
was like yeah the kind of spicy you're
like you know when you you kill the
burps keep coming up you're like
a little bit but it was great that's how
you know it's good the flavor was
amazing they finally upped it uh next
time I gotta be like hey where was the
chicken though it was like one bite so
next time you ride that one like hey so
where's the chicken it'll just be a
whole chicken
just keep challenging them and they'll
just like keep upping it well now I know
that their list they're actually reading
the special instructions yeah which I
thought they would anyway but I guess
sometimes they just don't sometimes
they're like [__] you yeah I'm not
listening to yourself unless it's your
damn special instructions someone named
Connor how are you with a Vietnamese
food when you're in Vietnam because I
know I know it's Vietnamese food for
like Southeast Asian levels isn't that
spicy no I would definitely there's a
there's a tier list of spiciness when it
comes to Southeast Asia yeah and it's
from least spicy to most spicy it's
Filipino Vietnamese and then like
Indonesia Malaysia and Thailand like up
here yeah so it's like you can choose
spiciness if you want it's like a choice
like with Filipino food but it's not
like oh with or without the spice makes
a difference like our Thailand just
removed the choice no no you will die
yeah you will get used to sound like
this is how it works you're gonna take
it away I mean I understand why they
would do it but also I I mean I know
this history behind it why not yeah and
stuff and spice stores better yada yada
but from just a modern day perspective
surely it ruins your taste buds going
anywhere else in the world you're like
man nothing is spicy anymore no okay I I
I don't agree with that just because
you [__] you actually spices Superior
everything could be improved with spice
no I don't think that's true uh I think
Thai Cuisine especially is just like the
way it's cooked and the way it's
flavored it just pretty much lends to
having some spice yes uh and because I
don't like all spicy food I've talked
about this before like having the you
know Japanese Curry and having like the
different tears of spice and sometimes
there's a point where you just feel like
you're adding Spice in artificially and
that just like that ruins this it's not
like spice that's integrated into the
dishes like kind of spiced on top you
see the cookware she added a new level
have they added a new level 15 now do
you just like take a scoop of like the
chili powder and just like you yeah it
comes with a side of like bowl of chili
how bad can it be yeah well I mean I
can't do 10 so can't attempted to order
it now yeah I only found out because of
course every Japanese YouTuber was like
oh if we ordered it right now would you
try to take a teaspoon I'll try it let's
order it let's order the 15. are you
serious let's do it
we'll get a small we'll get a small
we'll just I want to see how bad it is
how bad could it be all right it's
pretty bad I wasn't expecting to die
today no no it's a little bit it's just
a cocoy tree they they do one to ten and
the ten is it's pretty bad actually it's
I don't know I don't know what the [__]
they are okay mind you just just for
reference this is how we keep people
hooked as well
for reference my the the comfortable
level for me is level three right right
and I've tried level four because
because and you know that's a glob
considering me you've done well yeah
you've done well I used to I used to
think level one was like look at the low
carb Curry thank you because that was my
other concern yeah like I used to I'd
say like before these guys move
it jumps from 10 just to 15. there's no
like
no
it's like 15 but yeah I'm ordering yeah
but like for reference like before these
guys move to Japan I was not as used to
eating spicy food yeah um or you know I
couldn't handle it as well it's only
thanks to like me eating spiced food
with these guys and just doing like you
know like the spicy Ramen and like the
ghost pepper and [__] that I've had to
do for video has definitely helped me
having just one Ghost Pepper in your
life reframes like spice for your body
yeah it like makes you re-evaluate what
a jalapeno means yeah yeah jalapenos
used to be like oh spicy to like oh this
is a nice garnish yeah I could I I legit
couldn't even like eat a habanero I love
having it yeah I remember a video of you
eating a habanero and you're just dying
oh yeah I mean back then I was like
jalapenos were like my Max but I could
go to I'll tell you about I told you
that one time I made like chili with uh
ghost pepper right yeah yeah or what
when I did that I I don't know if I told
this on the podcast but I basically put
two ghost peppers in because I thought
for like a batch of chili of like eight
people yeah like I would be fine it
would level out it didn't have to happen
like that and I gave some to my
housemate and she was just dying she was
like bright red be like yeah you had a
little spice too I was like yeah a
little bit I had two Peppers ghost
peppers yeah but it was fun see the
thing the thing I you know as a Thai
person I when when I like spice I want
chilies I want fresh chilies I don't I
don't like so much like chili sauce I
don't like you know dunk it in a [__]
ton of chili sauce I want like the fresh
chilies I want to see the chili seeds in
the dish that I'm cooking because to me
that gives a much more like that fresher
kind of like spice like feeling uh
that's not kind of like artificial like
if I have like too much chili sauce it
just upsets my stomach I feel like but
that's the thing right it's like you
know when I had the ghost pepper right I
completely understand you know the whole
concept of adding like Chili Peppers or
like ghost peppers into a dish right
because the the spice complements the
Baseline flavor of whatever the dishes
Thai food for example like Vietnamese
food like yeah I can totally see why
this is necessary but when I had the
when I had the ghost pepper on stream it
was like the ghost pepper itself doesn't
really have flavor yeah in my opinion
it's like I ate into bell pepper but it
had gunpowder inside of it yeah like
it's like there's no like yeah this is
delicious the only flavor is just pan
yeah it's just pain well that's like
when I did that do the one chip
challenge and I thought it was just like
it can't be that bad because people do
it yeah and I thought you know if it's
really bad people wouldn't be doing it
that one was pretty [__] bad that was
like I think it was Carolina Reaper and
that one was like it tasted like two of
them yeah if it's just one chip I assume
it's going to be the spiciest pepper
yeah it's so [__] come concentrated
yeah I'm good dog yeah ain't it that's
just uh let's just [__] take pure
capsaicin or whatever it's called you
know let's uh let's call up Nigel [__]
that's cures
my stomach hurts thinking about this
cookie she's coming I still haven't
recovered from this Thai food yeah you
know I wanted to have a good day today
you know I had my weekly existential
crisis because okay
I uh I I was just lying in bed and uh
you know just next to Sydney it was
first thing in the morning and she's
just like hmm
is that a gray hair I see over there
Sydney don't say that don't don't I
think you could Rock gray hair though
huh I think you'll look great with gray
I mean I think okay here's here's the
thing right so now I don't I don't mind
having gray hair yeah I know okay this I
know this sounds like [__] copious
yeah you wear turtlenecks yeah you are
built I'll build people with gray hair
yeah you're gonna look great and it'll
complete the full Arc of gigu's hair
full anime Pro tag to to mellowed out to
Southeast Asian man yeah yeah you're
gonna go from anime enthusiasts to like
[__] Southeast Asian mathematics yeah
so excited I don't mind having like the
odd gray hair if if I am growing oh my
God I can't believe I'm talking about
this on a podcast but whatever but like
it's it just put like a thoughts in my
head right just to be like life is a few
times
I am getting old because
um whenever this video is coming out so
like
my next uh my next video that I've been
working on this week which will probably
be out uh it's kind of like a [__]
it's it's a full-on [__] d-gen anime
like full-on DJ and manga kind of level
oh yeah and I'm just like I remember
like it was that day where Sydney told
me I had a gray hair took the shower
started writing my script and I'm just
like
how much longer can I get away with
doing this [__] talking about
degenerative yeah yeah because like
I remember when I was younger right my
parents would be like you're gonna grow
out of anime someday you know you're
you're grow out of this phase someday
you're gonna grow up and then I just
never did okay and to be fair I do not
think I'm ever going to grow out of like
anime or gaming or this [__] that like
our parents told us we grew out of yeah
sure when we were younger but there are
certain things where I'm like
can I get away with this I know you came
to the realization I came to about two
years ago oh yeah yeah yeah well it's
like I I think obviously anime being
well it's not new but in terms of like
having more of a fandom around in the
west it's certainly yeah more on the
newer end compared to something like
let's say Star Wars which has been
around since what 80.
you know and you you look at like the
demographic people go to Comic-Con
you're like a lot of you dudes are like
your 50s or late 40s and it's like well
clearly
this is not like nowadays we are past
the because obviously the consuming
media and this type of stuff is all kind
of new and like this generation or the
current generation that's alive so it's
like I think I don't think it's like you
grow out of it anymore I think it's you
if you're if you're still understand
when you're 30 yeah you'll still be into
that thing or something adjacent to it
at 50 yeah 60. I think specific maybe
talking about anime titties yeah you
might do that less yeah okay okay
when do you think you're gonna stop
liking anime ludes on Twitter at what
age do you think it will be become
definitely the moment I have a kid for
sure
um I think I think the moment I have a
kid I'm probably just gonna like just
cut back on social media entirely yeah
yeah which is like I think that's what I
think yeah which I think is the way to
go but it's like yeah double it give it
to the next person make the kid the news
now being handled by my son uh so
anything he likes and you like Junior
yeah Junior's gonna like it so uh you
know his taste it's all his taste now
yeah it's got nothing to do with me yeah
because I'm I've had this thought
because I came to the cam same
conclusion where it's just gonna be like
okay when me and Sydney eventually have
kids that's probably going to be a huge
Catalyst to change some of our Behavior
but just because I know that you know
it's gonna become less socially
acceptable to let's say talk about this
in public it's just something in my
brain Gonna Change to be like okay
actually anime titties uh uncool now you
should you should not like this stuff
because I think so yeah you think so is
that I think it's like a gradual change
of like taste like maybe one thing that
was super lewd you might not be as
comfortable interacting with that kind
of stuff yeah but you still like loot
stuff but it's like okay you're slowly
maybe going away from that yeah I mean
even just like your opinions on life
yeah like that happens all the time I
mean even just like my taste in like you
know like the more degenerative shows or
whatever like I remember there were so
many shows when I was like 13 to 15
years of age where I'm just like oh it's
lewd Masterpiece this is the this is the
greatest piece the greatest piece High
School of the Dead
some of them are still great just
because of the other components that
made that show great but you know I
would say a good 80 of those like lewd
shows that I used to think were like
great shows I look at it now and I'm
just like yeah
and it's not like and you know maybe
it's because I've just like grown out of
that phase or maybe you have a
girlfriend well yeah or maybe because I
touch grass I don't know
by the way my tastes have definitely
changed but I don't regret that because
I feel that's just the natural process
for anyone regardless of whether you
[__] do it for a living or not right
it's like yeah obviously the shows that
you know you thought were [__]
amazing back in the day yeah in and you
look back at in retrospect you probably
think to yourself it either didn't age
as well or you're just like it's not
really my wheelhouse anymore yeah you
know I think that's interesting as well
because on the podcast we always talk
about what we like dislikes our opinions
and stuff because that's all we ever do
yeah and I've noticed that it started
happening more and more where people be
like oh he is one of us says something
that contrary someone we said three
years ago yeah and it's like okay trash
is gonna get to that point where as
we're growing older and we're changing
our opinions and our views on things
yeah we're obviously going to contradict
what we said three years ago yeah
because we're going to change our mind
on this isn't it it's so weird having to
do that isn't it insane to think that
opinions change well it's not crazy
isn't it insane to think that we just
say dumb [__] yeah sometimes we don't
speak but I can understand why a viewer
can get that because it's like you have
this kind of
want it's like a a cat like a a complete
video that is a complete Recreation of
you three years ago it's completely
there and you saying that thing and it's
still you today who is that person in
the video so it's very easy I think for
a person to think that why would their
opinion change because I It Feels So
recent and so accessible this opinion
yeah when obviously you said it three
years ago yeah and they don't see the
entire Journey or follow that entire
journey of how you changed your mind
yeah on things yeah sometimes it doesn't
even it's not even like a matter of like
time you know it could just be something
like you thought about this one thing
maybe because you were you know
uneducated in it or you didn't have
enough information you didn't have
enough of like a scope on it and then
once you got the more full picture and
you really thought it through then
you're like oh you know what maybe my
prior opinion on that was just wrong or
you know isn't wasn't reflective of what
I think now in my current headspace and
you know that could happen as early as
like [__] within the year with some
people you know it's like sometimes one
yes yeah some one person could say one
thing that just completely shifts your
mind on it and yeah your your opinions
change on that forever but on the world
of the internet where any video of any
timeline is accessible at any time
someone will look at and be like oh look
see he's contradictioning himself I'm
like who doesn't ever everyone
contradicts themselves that's what an
opinion is opinions are supposed to
change yeah did you did you guys okay
like going back to what it means like
grow up and like change your opinion
like be an adult did you guys have this
like image of let's say you're like you
know in your late teens going into like
you know 17 18 year olds going to
University or whatever and you had like
this image about how adults are like
supposed to act like oh once you finish
High School adults are meant to act this
way or once I finish University going to
the Working World adults are meant to
act that way and then you you actually
do grow up uh and you go into the
Working World you go into University and
you just have this like image in your
mind about how people your age are
supposed to act and then you've realized
holy [__] the people do not act the way
that I thought they would at all there's
that but there's also the opposite where
it's like you you look at an adult say
like your parents right or your dad or
whatever and you think like
not every dad likes this kind of [__]
like I'm not gonna be like that when I
get older and then you know and then you
grow up and you're like holy [__] I used
to think trips to Ikea were boring as
[__] and now I'm super excited to see
this new couch like and it's not even
like a matter of like you know you
growing up it's just like oh this is
just like a natural progression that
every adult goes through whether you
like it or not and it's like and it's
not and you get old enough to the point
where you realize oh it's not even cool
trying to go against that grain because
now everyone's doing it yeah you know
it's like there isn't a single adult out
there who's like you like Furniture
[__] Normie like no one's like that
it's like it's just a natural thing that
like as an adult there's nothing wrong
with and it's completely a natural
progression to just adopt those like
interests and styles regardless of how
you label how you grow up right I have a
question okay when did you
like obviously we turn 18 we're adults
yeah yeah what did you feel like you
became an adult
uh still waiting yeah oh really okay
okay I it's it's hard like when do you
feel like that you felt that you were
comfortable in like who you were as a
person and as an adult I would say
26. I'm still alive
it's so uncomfortable I'm still
uncomfortable with those things because
one thing I I there was this feeling
that I always struggled to to shake and
I don't know where this comes from but
you know when you like let's say maybe
maybe this is because I I went straight
into youtubing after finishing
University we only turn up to a place
and because we were like we're like
we're like YouTubers and stuff and I
don't know what it is but like you feel
that like everyone is like doing their
job yeah and you feel like you are like
fake at being there yeah being like
present like you feel that everyone
knows their role and you feel like
you're faking that you're involved in
this every time I get invited to like a
company outing or like a fancy dinner
party and [__] I'm just like I am a
child yeah I I should not I make YouTube
videos I should not be yeah even though
all the adults around you are just like
yeah he's gonna he's got a job he's
making money he's got his own business
he's an entrepreneur but like in your
mind you're just like no I'm not I'm
just a [__] kid making dumb videos on
the internet and somehow making a living
like I don't feel like all of you actual
professional adults yeah whatever that
means I think I think my one of the
biggest realizations I had when I was
like fully an adult was uh yeah growing
up I thought the one thing that would
happen when I went into the Working
World was I'd realized that people would
suddenly become competent and then I
soon realized that in no matter which
industry no matter where you are uh
there will always be incompetent people
and they'll especially somehow be
incompetent people in higher uh
positions of high power yeah like no
matter what and I it would I I just had
this image that I was like in [__]
University I'm just like dealing with
this University kids I'll just be like
everyone here's a [__] idiot when I
get into the Working World people are
only start to make sense the World's
Gonna Make Sense people will do their
jobs and then I went into the Working
World and people still didn't do it and
you're like damn adults are dumb
adults are [__] dumbass is this what
being an adult is like just realizing
that the world is actually incompetent
and everyone's coping with the fact like
damn did you live like this holy [__]
I'm like how are you adulting how the
[__] do you do these companies function
and then somehow these companies do
function but you go into the companies
at like a you know either either an
entry level you see how the company
functions internally and you're like how
is this how how does the world turn I
don't understand when there are this
many incompetent people in the world
maybe this is just a me thing it's
people like that that make me realize
like oh you can be a dumb ass adult and
still survive yeah yeah well I I think
yeah because you're you remember that
one guy who [__] everything up more
than the 10 guys who did their job yeah
yeah exactly is it here already yeah wow
like I thought that one guy who does
nothing in a group project was like a
school thing you know I I I I know I
thought that one guy who guy who sits
around and does nothing and takes all
the credit for the group project was a
school thing and then I've realized that
this is just a world that's called a CEO
it's people like that who end up in high
positions of power
but yes I am present you just hope right
you hope that those people don't get
rewarded for that and then people who
work hard do and yeah that's kind of the
trust you have in the systems yeah who
work hard you just hope they'll be
Reckoning and you know like and it's
interesting right because it's like that
one kid in every school project that as
you were saying like [__] it just
shows up but takes all the credit yeah
you know some of those people just never
grow out of them they're just like oh I
mean it worked in school it probably
works as an adult let's see how it goes
yeah yeah and then there are some people
I feel uh who are in that position
during school and they're just like wait
this works in a school environment right
if I did that [__] in the real world I'm
getting sacked dog like I'll be out of a
job oh if you're not in Japan if you're
not in Japan in Japan they're just like
we've gained the system yeah just show
up and don't do anything and you
okay I don't know if this is a loaded
question but do you guys feel like
adults I already asked that
[Music]
okay so to reiterate on that question
though what would you say is the
defining feature of what you consider an
adult I think
like what is the difference between an
adult and a still a [__] like uh
young guy I think that being an adult
means feeling like you have a place in
the world and you have a purpose and if
you're serving a goal whether it's
yourself or working in a company and you
feel that you're in something that is is
right for you and you're you're
benefiting yourself or whatever it is
I think it's like when to yourself it
feels that way right I think Society is
it the term adult yeah 18 but I think
yeah the moment you internalize like
when you feel that like you yourself
have like figured it not figured it out
but like you feel that okay I've I'm
starting to get a grasp on this life
thing yeah because when you're like the
the pieces start to fall in place right
yeah because like I think what you just
said
all right we'll do we'll do that later
um like I I feel like what you just
described is pretty much like the almost
like the opposite for me because when I
feel like an adult uh when I when I
first started to feel like an adult is
when I first started to feel like lost
and I kind of realized holy [__]
everyone my age feels lost you because
when you think that you found like we're
as an adult you're striving to find that
place where you kind of feel like you
know your place in the world you're
bringing something useful I know so many
[__] people let's say like I think
most people don't feel that yeah most
people most people don't feel that way
most people like that I've met in like
the mid to early 20s to like sometimes
late 30s early 40s they feel [__]
lost and they're like I do not know what
I am contributing yeah uh and I do not
know where my place and you think that
feeling of being lost equates to being
an adult the shared experience yeah of
that loss being lost yeah I feel like
because when when you are a teenager you
think that you're just gonna suddenly
figure it out and I remember getting
like I remember getting my first like
getting my first acceptance letter for
like my first real job which you all
know what it is I thought [__] yeah I I
thought maybe she mentioned I thought to
myself [__] this is it I am finally an
adult I've made it man I've got my first
job actually gonna have disposable
income gonna get a paycheck worked there
for a year and I felt more lost than
when I started and I feel like that
experience is probably not going to be
an alien experience for a lot of people
and then when I started feeling more
comfortable was when I talked to people
and I was like oh this isn't a me thing
this is an everyone thing we're all
feeling the same way we all have no
[__] clue see but then like I would
argue you know you said that like during
you know like high school or whatever
there's a lot of people who are just
like yeah I have like a set plan I'm
gonna figure that [__] out but I don't
know me personally I feel lost as [__]
during high school because I was just
kind of like I I understood that in this
school environment is the norm though
yeah but that's the thing right it's
like so it's interesting you say that
the feeling of being lost made you feel
like an adult because I feel like when I
was lost it made me feel like I was
still a child because I was still trying
to figure out my place in society and
then it's when I finally figured out
what I wanted to do which was this whole
YouTube creative thing
um that's when I started to be like okay
this isn't like games there's just games
and play anymore like this is like a
serious
occupation this is a serious job for me
now yeah and like even though I still
you know treat that whole business and
occupation as you know with a lot of fun
and you know uh casual you know way I
also understand that the back of my mind
I'm like if I [__] this up then it's not
just a matter of like oh well no I've
lost a hobby or I've lost a thing that I
like like I have lost a job like I am
you know and that creates serious
consequences in my life so I feel like
for me it was the opposite being in the
middle is consequences I think I think
yeah yeah because in high school if you
[__] up you had people around you
there to support you right whether it
you know and you know obviously not
every high school kid has this
particular very three different
interpretations yeah yeah I mean I
because I feel like I think they'll have
valid things as well yeah yeah
absolutely I think they just come from
our own subjective life experience
because I feel like we are all in very
lucky positions now
um and that we do have a job which we
find fulfilling you know that is a
[__] Rarity and that is a goal that
everyone strives to get and I feel so
[__] blessed every day I wake up and
I know that I'm doing something that I
find fulfilling because doing like three
four years of an unfulfilling job uh
working for a company is that's soul
sucking and people have done that for
far longer than I had to experience so
you know it's it's something I think we
have to acknowledge that
I you know I feel like we've found our
purpose in life absolutely a lot earlier
than some other people may have found
yet isn't it interesting that even
though we you know as far as what we've
talked about of the definition of being
an adult Yeah by definition since we
have found a job that is an actual
legitimate job and we find satisfaction
and we feel fulfilled it which is what
we have kind of lightly defined as being
an adult yeah yet if you ask any
traditional media about YouTubers
they'll be like oh these [__] kids
just [__] around I don't know
and it's like it's it's interesting like
this this disparity of like having a a
stable job I guess or like you know a
real world job that's not like you know
content creation on YouTube is it
considered like the adult choice and yet
I'm sure there's a lot of people in
those like job fields who maybe don't
feel that way themselves yeah I mean
like I feel like times change a lot and
you just got to adapt with the times of
being like [__] 40 years ago you were
you was looked like a degenerate child
if you're still living with your parents
uh at the age of like 30 or 28 and now
with like the reality of the world is
that the housing then rent prices are so
[__] high give me money and I'll [__]
get the [__] out like that there are a
lot of people who still live with their
parents not because they are a deadbeat
degenerate Financial Choice it's a wise
Financial Choice and they still have a
job that they commute to yeah from like
with their parents and it's just like a
smart thing to do nowadays you know what
I'm saying it's just like the way the
world is
but like what I okay so you're an adult
when you feel like an adult I feel at
the end of the day yeah I guess what I
was trying to get is like how do you
like what is the turning point or what
is that the series of thoughts or
emotions that make you feel that way
because obviously of course you feel
like an adult when you're an adult
whatever yeah but like how what is the
what what is that okay at least for me
personally it's the feeling of every
action I take from here on out every
choice I make from here on out have real
life consequences whether that be good
or bad I think I think the term you're
looking for is responsibility yes
that's it I am responsible for
everything I do everything I say who I
interact with how I interact with
everything in my world is now directly
going to come back to me there's no
parent buffer there's no teacher buffer
there's no anyone in between to like
hold your hands I always wanted that
though as a kid yeah I hated the fact
that I was tied to like
my you know not not in a bad way but
like tied everything was directly tied
to my parents in some way I always
wanted to have Independence well and I
think that's why a lot of high school
kids you know have that feeling of like
I want to be an adult yeah yeah but one
of The Independents so I'm American
do you do you ever like you know you
know you like as a kid the kind of like
stereotype is there are kids who grow up
way too fast and they miss like their
let's say childhood or things that you
can only experience as a kid do you feel
like
do you feel like they're a parts of your
childhood that you do miss or as a kid
where you just like I just want to be an
adult as fast as possible uh and it's
kind of like let's say met the hype of
everything that you thought being an
adult as a kid I mean I think I think
there's a lot of again we have to which
bear in mind that I think it's different
right because I think that again like
you said we're very we're success
someone we do so obviously
being successful at whatever age or you
know having money at 23 is obviously
like great whatever I'm like that's
awesome that's so much better than being
23 and having to work two jobs just to
pay rent yeah that's like and I think
that's not on the person from their
childhood I think that's just purely of
like boy you dealt a good hand in life
where you [__] did you make any big
mistakes that came back to haunt you
like I guess there's a bunch of reasons
so it's hard to like be like I I think
it's it's impossible to be like
predetermined if you were going to be
someone who like thought that your
childhood was better yeah I think it's
something that just happens this [__] up
happens like what if you uh you know you
you had a you was you had a really good
childhood but you were super you
couldn't wait to be an adult you matured
whatever and maybe you got like a bad
car crash and then maybe you can't you
lost you know maybe you're blind or
maybe like something bad happened to you
or maybe a loved one died it's like okay
well that would completely change how
you view all of this stuff following and
you would obviously look back at your
childhood in a lot more like kind of uh
what's the word uh Nostalgia yeah uh
because you're like oh everything was
fun and safe and great back then I could
play video games and drink ribena and it
was fun like yeah I guess we can only
really talk about our personal yeah I
mean we can only talk about our personal
experiences however I do think that uh I
if I had to go back I'd probably still
be enjoy being a kid because all I
always play video games and that's kind
of what I want to do now okay question
what age if you could go back in time to
your childhood right for let's say a
week to experience it again how old
would you be do being like 15 16 was
like the best age I love that because I
felt old enough to enjoy [__] and be
mature about it yeah I hated the exams
obviously yeah but I felt like I was
caught like I was I was mature enough
but I could still spend all day playing
video games I I would go back to like
12. 12 or 12. I think 12. because
because at like 12 is like kind of that
point where you're like you know
transitioning from primary school or
Elementary School to high school at
least in Australia right and I feel like
just you're taking more serious a little
bit more seriously than while you're in
elementary school but you still have all
of the benefits of being out fresh out
of elementary school right like you can
you can do like more like kind of
childlike activities and like be okay
with it you know you can you can
basically indulge in all your hobbies
right whether they're like more mature
or less mature for your age like you
know I could I could do all of like the
more immature I guess like high school
Hobbies at the same time but I if but if
I wanted to [__] stay at home and you
know watch anime for 15 hours while you
know sucking on my thumb then I can also
do that too like it's fine like you get
you're like take me back to and I like
that yeah
pay me back take me back to the time
where I could watch anything and I'd
probably enjoy it
as a jaded old man now I can't do that
anymore take me back to when I
discovered one piece and like yeah like
I [__] Marathon that [__] exactly as
an adult you just miss being able to not
feel bad about spending one week doing
[__] nothing yeah and now because
that was your whole life yeah so the
next time we had to do that is when we
retire yeah we're like 50 or 60 years
old and old man but we don't have the we
don't have as much energy as we did back
then so you're kind of limited to what
you can watch a lot of TV yeah you can
do that but I mean like to me I think I
can just boil it down like a sentence
which is like when was the last
Christmas I was actually excited about
you know
when I got that Nintendo Wii it was a
game changer yeah yeah and to me it was
like I think it was around like 12 13
years old that was like the last point
where I'm like oh I can actually get
presents it was when holidays actually
like mid-some right right it wasn't just
like I'm doing stuff with my family and
friends it was like a [__] event yeah
yeah it was nice it was nice in here too
you Christmas Day you're like damn I
gotta play Crash Bandicoot Spyro and
this new again I don't know which one to
do first
it was just the excitement of just being
like this is just gonna be a banger day
yeah the next week I am in heaven I'm
gonna play new video games that I can
only get this many video games at once
on this day I'm gonna eat some bang of
food yeah and uh it's just gonna be a
good day and that's that to me is kind
of like the pure happiness that I will
never experience again as an adult
because it's a different kind of it's
it's a different kind of Happiness which
you know it's we we I'm still I'm very
happy being an adult but you know there
is a certain type of happiness you feel
as a kid that I would love to experience
again just just once just
just and I feel the only way to like
realistically be able to experience that
again is when you have your own kids
where you can kind of live vicarious
seriously through the through the
enjoyment of watching your kids
experience that exact same thing that
you probably experienced as a kid as
well hopefully become an anime fan of
them yeah until yeah and then the moment
when my son or daughter comes after me
and they go what's one piece and I'll be
like rest in peace
that's Paul this episode is brought to
you by cash app with tools for staving
and spending it's the best place for you
to level up your money and glow up your
life listen boys I might not look it but
I'm a bit of a gamer more specifically a
jrpg player and if you guys have played
jrpgs then you would know that leveling
up in a video game is so important in
every aspect and every game so why don't
we use that same mentality in our real
lives level up our real life skills well
luckily cash app can help you do just
that on the financial side of your life
all it takes to pay someone is their
phone number email or cash tag you can
even scan their QR code straight from
the app and you'll see your balance
updated immediately so you always know
when a payment went through and not only
that you can get exclusive discounts
with cash out pay and cash card it's a
faster simpler way to bank without so
many fees now that I myself am an adult
I have to make sure that my finance
level is up to the Max and thankfully
cash app is there to help me get to that
point so download cash app in the app
store or Google play with the Link in
the description below with no hidden
fees and a free to order debit card it
feels like a cheat code for your
finances they get to cash out for
sponsoring this episode back to the
video I want to try this card before it
goes all right all right
I'll be the first one
I can already see this will be the most
replayed part of the episode I just
wanna I just wanna
I'll I'll take one little
test bro that looks viscous here can we
get some spoons oh my God it smells oh
smell that oh my god dude why is it so
thick oh my God that's like a paste yeah
it's crazy I mean uh oh oh
I'm very excited for this at all do we
have any milk that's fine it's fine I'm
sure no it won't I'm sure I'm gonna die
joe he's just not going to uh talk you
guys go first I'm gonna try this real
quick I'm gonna try a little bit all
right all right all right
that's all right I'll deal with water
how is it
um
it's not that bad actually is it not I
don't I I I do not trust these two as
opinion the thing about like actually
it's not it's not as bad as ten I
remember 10 being worse the thing about
the thing about this is that a few bites
isn't too bad but it's something it's
when you have like the whole thing that
you start I can smell that [__] hell
I can literally see like the uh curry
powder it's it's more powder than Curry
man they're like they're like salt
greens or curry powder in there
it's a little it's not awful the time
one I have yesterday was worse genuinely
it's not that bad you could try you
could do it you could do this you could
do this all right
the one bite not that bad one bite isn't
that bad it's when you have an entire
and it's going down your throat and I
work inside edition yeah no worries
peppery than it is like yeah spicy you
know
I mean it's definitely spicy don't get
me wrong it's spicy
I'm sweating a little bit
it's very peppery yeah yeah that's
that's it right yeah peppery kind of
spicy
being an adult is enjoying pepper at the
salt and pepper
spicy that's spicy it's not that bad
though it's as bad as time
I've never had 10 so I don't know
it's pretty uh I mean I didn't actually
make a video a whole video about eating
10 and yeah I didn't [__] eat it it
was like a 12 minute video about how bad
it was I don't think it was that bad
yeah but she can't eat level one oh okay
she's Filipino she doesn't eat spicy
food but I should do that with oranges
in the video I'm like oh man tries
Orange from Florida okay to be fair I
think because I've trained myself now in
the past couple years on that I've
that's not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be that's not bad it hurts but I
can deal with it that is the kind of
spice I don't like that's the that
that's so much like artificial spice
give me like a good Pepper Peppers the
Thai Peppers when I see them they strike
fear of me oh I know my digestive system
is going to be [__] the next day I've
been I've had I've [__] four times today
already
like okay so I'm sweating I guess go go
this can be an interesting being an
adult is being able to know that you're
gonna regret a decision and still make
it
when uh yeah I'm leaving that right now
if if or when you eventually have kids
would you try to give your kids like
would you try to make it so they don't
grow up too fast either or you know they
kind of have like
the chart like what is like a good
childhood you know what is a good
childhood that uh aside from obviously
just being in a good position uh having
Rich parents
being a nepo baby yeah no I don't know I
think I think it's the idea of you know
I would say I had a pretty good
childhood
um not because like my parents were like
well off or like you know I was like
[__] privileged or whatever you know
yeah that's all dependent on perspective
but like I think the one thing that made
my childhood really good was that my
parents were like open enough and were
understanding enough for me to be able
to pursue what I wanted to do yeah or
like pursue like even if it was like
[__] insignificant even if it was
something like uh you know hey Dad I
want to start playing tennis yeah you
know or like I want to learn how to play
the piano no son you shall not play
tennis yeah you know or it's like any
kind of like thing where it's like you
know I want to be I want to like learn
how to do this or like learn this skill
or be able to do this or play you know
this thing and as long as it wasn't like
2 [__] extreme like you know if if I
was 11 years old and I was like Dad I
want to skydive he'd just be like you're
you're on crack you know you know I'm
not gonna let you do that but you know
if it was just like you know like
childhood uh you know I guess
discoveries of like you know certain
things you want to do or certain uh
skills you want to try I think a good
childhood is having those parents that
just let you do it yeah and you know
being like all right we'll let you do it
if you don't end up liking it that's
totally fine if you end up liking it hey
good for you I think it's just having
that option open yeah you know because
there's a lot of like controlling
parents out there you will do exactly
this and this and this yeah they're so
tired of me swapping Hobbies all the
time oh so they were like [__] sake
pick something yeah we just pick
something and stick with it for [__]
sake that's why it's in my parents it's
a [__] miracle I've done YouTube for
10 years because they thought for sure I
was gonna get bored of it I know what I
liked all right it's not gonna
compromise yeah if I didn't want if I
thought I liked [__] playing
badminton and I thought it sucked
afterwards like I had hobbies that
lasted like 90 even a week but it's the
fact I think that my parents let me
discover for myself whether it was
something I actually wanted to do or not
to find a good childhood but I guess
that's also like I guess that is that's
not like privilege but also obviously
you have to be a bit well off to allow
to pay for your kids to do this kind of
stuff because oh yeah you know nowadays
I feel like this it's a lot harder to be
like hey yeah I can I can afford to give
you piano lessons that are probably
never gonna come to anything and I mean
mind you there were some there were some
things as well that I was like Hey I
want to do this thing and my parents
were just like we don't have the money
for that fair enough yeah so like they
were fair about it you know so they
obviously thought they were like all
right is it financially viable
[__] Mario the theme song for my
phone yeah
nobody else's [__] you Jerry my dad
always used to say like I'm putting that
on the tab yeah
when you have to pay me back as an adult
every time I was like Dad can I buy this
like candy and he's just like how much
is it and he looks and he's like all
right I'm putting it on the tab and so
as a kid I did ask Lord I had this like
[__] IOU that my dad was like keeping
track of being like I was just prepared
for when I turned 18 for my dad just be
like happy 18th birthday
how much money your parents have spent
on you yeah no just out of no for no
reason just no reason just to see a
number that was like this is how much we
spoke I mean it would give me a good
idea of how much I have to spend on my
kid right so I thought you better say
pay them back but you're like no yeah I
am the gift Joe finishes University and
he gets the student loan and his dad
comes along he's like this is the real
load yeah this is
can you Google what's the average amount
parents spend on their kids in their
entire like life I'm sure because I know
this I remember there's a figure like 10
years ago but 10 years is nothing
watching this thing and like you know
when you watch things and they mention
like money and then like in today's
money it's this yeah yeah and then
you're like oh man that's crazy that's
so long ago and you're like it's only
100 years ago you're like oh [__] wait
I'll be alive for like most of that yeah
so my money could go from being like
nothing to something if I if I just held
on to it oh yeah that's literally every
person who like bought a house like
that's like your parents age just like
we bought this [__] seven bedroom
full bathroom Mansion for like twenty
thousand dollars and it's like today
it's like oh I can buy a shoebox for 1.5
million that's just every American
realizing how young their country is
yeah and uh how how much of their
lifetime they've already I mean I get it
Australia was the exact same thing bro
yeah
300 okay so one child all right for one
Three Brothers future future my future
shout if you're watching this I expect
the 300K back by the time yeah I'm gonna
write it I'm going to actually start a
test
I I wish my dad actually kept the time
so that as an adult I could be like all
right let me see how much it would be
super interesting and hindsight to be
like we spent how much on this weird
hobby for you yeah I'm sure people don't
keep track right I I just just because I
love looking at numbers and it's so fun
seeing data yeah like all line bro I
went to piano lessons for like 15 years
I don't want to think about how much
money my parents did you choose to do
piano lessons or did you I did so how it
ended up happening was who uh my sister
was actually the one who was like I want
to learn how to play piano and you know
my mom was always like you know I've
been the Asian parent she was always
like Oh My My Asian child wants to learn
an instrument and it's piano
destiny
so we bought like an upright piano for
the house right and my sister was like
learning how to play at this point I
hadn't started at all my sister I would
just watch my sister like practicing and
kind of struggle because I guess piano
wasn't really a thing and then I would
jump on the piano and I would without
any lessons just be able to play the
exact same thing my sister was he's a
Survivor what a flex and then that's
what my parents are like I think we
should get you in instead of my sister
so my sister immediately quit after that
and then I filled her place right and
then I did it for 15 years so it's like
my parents my parents were probably
thinking like oh thank God the
investment on that piano didn't go to
waste because if I'd never picked it up
and my sister would have quit then we
would have just had a [__] dust
dust-filled piano just in our house but
fair enough it was actually put to good
use thankfully do you know why I saw a
guitar why I'm about to call out my mum
here so because it wasn't actually my
decision to start guitar or I didn't
have like a real like I don't think I
had interest in it but my mum was like
I'm signing you up to guitar lessons
like okay why and she's like you'll get
girls
did you really yeah she was like your
mom got the rest
[Music]
she was like girls like you when guys
play guitar I'm signing up photos
that is sure
I thought it was gonna be like a status
symbol thing because often it's seen as
a status symbol to make your kid as
talented in an instrument right yeah
yeah play the thing boys come on now
play the piano entertain my guess I
think it's more like a piano or like a
violin or like it's like classy my mom
just like tried to get like tried to
like Risk me up she's like this this
will be useful in life one day and then
I just started playing guitar and I I
think I was like as a kid I just like I
was the type of kid that just did things
because people told me to do it I didn't
really use a sheep
and I just continued doing guitar
lessons and then like accidentally
started a band just because I kept doing
guitar lessons
sorry so uh so basically the whole
reason why nine and a half pounds exists
is because of your mom yeah yeah yeah
let's go yeah I I never did any
instruments I actually did try to learn
drums but I just realized I just didn't
understand Rhythm
he was trying to teach me it and I was
like it just doesn't make sense to me
what do you mean
just like I he would try and teach me
like basic [__] I'm like I just don't
get it like I would I would be able to
replicate it yeah yeah but it would be
because I like had to translate it in my
head into like uh like like ones and
twos or like hitting numbers yeah like I
had a like a sensor like a counting
system like a robot essentially like I I
can't recognize the Rhythm as like a a
thing I just I can't listen to it I
can't replicate it right so I gave up on
that pretty quickly
um and then I just did Sports a lot of
sports but only I only really like the
sports where it was like I I hated team
sports because I hated having to be in a
team League of Legends yeah exactly I
hated having to rely on other people all
right you sound so [__] anime MC I
don't need other people but I genuinely
like hated Sports where I had to like I
was part of a team because I I wasn't
very good no I'm totally the same that's
why I started tennis yeah well so I
didn't like that's a 1v1 bro yeah yeah
tennis but then I got into squash known
as racquetball
under squash as it's called in the UK
or as I like to call it privileged
tennis it's normally like yeah it's
what's weird is I I guess like when I
left the UK I realized how bizarre this
is like almost every
every Sports Center in Wales at least
I'm not sure about England
um they would have a squash court really
every single Sports Center they'd have a
tennis court they'd have uh is it big in
Wales oh it's pretty big in the UK I
guess it must be yeah it's pretty big
and they'd have like those there's the
like the giant concrete walls the glass
front so yeah yeah and like every a lot
of people played it but then I realized
when watching American like TV that it
was only played by like super rich
businessmen when they wanted to like
talk yeah and it was like oh I used to
play that in school a lot it was golf or
squash yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so I
played that I played uh I was on I I
guess by default I I played for Wales
for a little bit because there was there
wasn't many of us it was like number
like 19 or something number eight and
Wales no it's terrible uh it wasn't very
out of 19 plays yeah
like the rankings uh and uh yeah it was
fun I like that and because I liked the
fact that I could just Sprint and hit a
ball really hard yeah because tennis was
so much about like technique and being
elegant
yeah and I I my brother did it as well
so I and it was kind of interesting
because we were like the Opposites I was
always looking to like smash it as hard
as I could yeah like an ogre like and I
was very fat like because I was I was I
was very good at sprinting so I was very
good at sprinting and smacking really
hard whereas my brother was really good
at technique right being like smiling
about it uh well we never played
together because he was in an older
bracket but yeah so I just I was just a
neanderthal uh right I was like hit it
everything I wanted to do I wanted to
just rely on like raw uh ability I never
wanted to study I never cared about get
like learning to get better I was like I
just want to be good at something you're
right just do it yeah over and over
again it's it's always weird to see to
like talk to people and just see how
many like weird hobbies and phases they
went through as a kid because like yeah
I remember when I was in like middle
school or high school or something I was
like on my like teams basketball team oh
my God
I mean the only reason I joined was
because uh we had PE and the coach was
like you should join the basketball team
and I'm like why and she's like you're
tall and I'm like okay now I only joined
because it was I read slam dunk and I
was like I want to [__] play this
game of course it was Joey I wasn't I
was the shortest dude in my team I'm
just like no no don't worry I can be
like meatly I'm I can be a short sprinty
fast guy in the team and I'll be good I
did that for like a few months and then
I was just like this is too hard yeah
were you were you any good at it I was
decent at it but I think it's because
like because I'd grown up doing a lot of
like Ball Sports like soccer and like
tennis and like just a whole variety of
them and like I did a bit of like
baseball and cricket and stuff like that
as well but nothing yeah too seriously I
think I was just yeah I did a bit of
baseball what the [__] yeah when I'd
come to Japan uh like I would have like
some friends who like play a bit of
baseball I've never played baseball I
think sometimes it's fine when I
explained to America I'm like no no we
we do not know anything about baseball
we don't under we don't know it it's we
don't have it no dude baseball would be
the perfect sport for you because
because if you're a batter you just have
to think to yourself I need to hit this
ball as hard as I [__] can yeah and
as a Fielder you just have to think I
need to grab the ball and throw it back
as hard as I [__] can there's no like
there's like little bits of finesse in
it but it's not like squash or like
tennis where you have to like think
about yourself
techniques to it there is technique but
not as much as like squash I don't know
yeah I don't know I don't know if this
is going to get my passport revoked
um I think like baseball is funner than
Cricket to play at least because I had
like one baseball uh we're in in peace I
have no strong things about cricket by
the way I have no strong affiliation
okay okay
because okay so we had like you know in
PE uh in high school and everything we
had like you know viewership drops
of Americans uh but yeah
one baseball lesson uh in in rpe class
because I guess there was like one of
our gym uh gym teachers was just like
really really [__] into baseball and
I'm like I've I despised every Cricket
lesson I ever had I was just like maybe
I just hate the act of hitting a ball
that's thrown at me on a stick and then
I realized that when I played baseball
for some reason it was just so much more
satisfying when you just get the strike
in like way more than it was for Cricket
for me I don't know why I just I
something about the way baseball I think
it's because swinging a bat like this
yeah I think it's just more natural yeah
than swinging about like this yeah yeah
you know like holding something like
this when something is coming you've got
to wear all that stuff as well yeah yeah
because otherwise you're gonna have
severe injuries well I mean in baseball
if the pitcher is [__] you're gonna get
you know you're gonna get a fastball at
you yeah it's still dangerous yeah yeah
both both I think I think uh the ball
for Cricket is obviously like a little
bit harder oh that thing is a rock
Cricket's [__] yeah I hated that the
amount of times that ball has just like
smacked right into my shin and left the
biggest bruise on me while playing
Cricket oh my God yeah that shit's
painful yeah so yeah I don't know I've
always found baseball more fun but like
there were so many sports that I wanted
to get into when I was younger but I
just also didn't have like uh I really
wanted I really enjoyed hockey hockey
actually you're a normal hockey just
normal hockey ice hockey because in
America if you say hockey it means
that's hockey no yeah just field hockey
I guess yeah yeah I've really really
[__] enjoyed hockey uh but in England
at least that was more seen as like you
know that's that's like what the girls
do you know it's like the girls did the
girls did hockey and netball and the
guys played like basketball and football
you know yeah and I I was like [__] but
I I really actually really [__] enjoy
it I want to join the girls we don't
have a we didn't have a team in our
school but I really wanted to play it
more
um and uh yeah that's I really enjoyed
that was there a sport you always wanted
to do but never got the chance to
even if it's like just for like one time
just to see if you'll like even like it
or just interested in trying it the
sports where I'm like how the [__] did
you get it how do you get into that like
the the one where what's the uh
like how do you if the one where they
ski and shoot things like I'm like how
the [__] do you even get into it what's
what you know the in the Winter Olympics
when they they do like the really long
distance like ski walking yeah yeah
skiing but they're like oh going uphill
yeah and then they stop and pull a gun
out and start shooting targets I've
never seen that you've seen this I've
never seen it up okay what's it called
again
I'm curling I want to try I like killing
how the [__] do you get into I want to
try curl like I don't know like the
student Sports where I feel like I'd
Crush at and I'm like dude I feel like
as a kid if you let me do the what's it
called uh play pigeon shooting yeah I
feel like I'd pop off because I've got
the dog
I would but I'm like oh that's only for
people from a very wealthy backgrounds
yeah you had Royals close to a
connection to some kind of you say like
oh a lot of these sports are kind of
interesting you just never get to try
yeah you either don't live in a place
where it's done or you just don't have
the financial means to do it like
another one like that is like skiing or
something yeah that's that's something
that just requires being a bit more
wealthy to do yeah did you find a guy
no no
it's not like a machine gun it's like a
rifle pretty sure that's a scene from
James Bond right you know it's like a
mission impossible
he's off into the helicopter and Tom
Cruise slaloming down and then shooting
a [__] RPG at a helicopter
is a winter sport that combines
cross-country skiing and rifle shooting
it is treated as a race with contestants
skiing through a cross-country Trail
whose distance is divided into shooting
rounds so like how well you do on the
shooting gives you like time penalties
or thing it's really cool but a man is
is it like one of those Sports I'm like
how the [__] do you even get into this
because you you you're cross-country
skiing but a lot of it is like the the
skiing where you're like kind of having
to do the like running
it's pretty [__] hard work and then
on top of that you gotta whip out a
rifle and [__] shoot it it's
ridiculous I'm like who who came up with
this bro that's badass that is badass it
is dude I mean that's like average I
guess if you're just from Finland that's
just your childhood but for like other
countries I'm like who the [__] who the
[__] from like Morocco learn to do this
how do they learn to represent this
how did this happen it's like uh that's
just like Cool Runnings you know yeah
of Cool Runnings oh yeah I guess it's
like that it's like you're like how the
[__] was I was supposed to get into the
sport that looks cool like I'd love to
try and do pop sledding how the [__] do
I get into that yeah who do I go to am I
too old can I try now like what do I do
one one hobby that I kind of like am
interested in getting back into uh
because this is just like
I think everyone has like one Wild Card
that'd be a great hobby to have am I my
hearing hobby
uh I remember I went through a brief
period where I did like ballroom and
Latin America dancing oh
and I was actually really that would get
[__] fun that would raise people up
that would raise people up I'll send you
the wrong thing male dancers get so much
holy [__] so much yeah I mean I did it
because a mate kind of like dragged me
to do it yeah this is like this is like
in University phase uh he dragged me to
dirt because uh he uh wanted to meet
girls so he dragged me to bore him in
Latin America because he needed like he
needed the guy to go with him and I
ended up just really [__] enjoying it
and just doing it for two years because
it's actually really fun do you know
what's a male like uh like an activity
that you do as a male that gets you the
ultimate rears what [__] ballet
that [__] will get you ultimate res
every time like it sounds like a budget
like Alpha conversation yeah it is it is
welcome to the diet Alpha podcast hello
today I'm going to convince you why
doing ballet will get you ultimate risk
hello it is I Andrew cake uh we're gonna
talk about the alternate the ultimate
Alpha uh ballet ballet ballet's where
it's at yeah I mean uh yeah I mean I
think now uh I want to get back into it
because I think it'd just be a really
fun thing to do with Sydney unromantic
plus there is like I I will swear to God
there is nothing that makes you feel
like more powerful as a man than just
dancing the tango with a girl man I'm
jealous man because I have like absolute
zero coordination when it comes to
dancing I cannot I I I have as well to
be fair to to say this I sucked at it I
I was that one guy that just sucked
today because I suck at dancing but it
just was so so fun and that one time you
get the steps on and it's it's like you
know dancing like something like salsa
or Tango where you kind of like you as
that you have to like lead the girl so
what so like they have to like follow
your lead and there's just something so
[__] powerful about that feeling of
just being like okay for this one song
you have to follow everything I say and
everything I do not only that but that
comes in clutch at the retirement home
as well dog like if you're that one old
dude that could like hips break their
hips doing the salsa bro all the
grannies just be like that man's still
got the rest after all these years yeah
it is weird to like a lot of girls I
know actually did ballet when they were
younger then it's funny you bring up
ballet because Sydney did that I don't
know like maybe maybe it's a [__]
Midwestern country girl thing but every
uh every guy is what piano is to Asian
parents oh yeah it's ballet it's a white
parents yeah I'm just speculating
that's such a good analogy ballet is
just beautiful white parents man it's
like a hobby that I 99 of kids will drop
and one percent will keep doing it yeah
and the one percent that holds on to it
become like savants
this episode is sponsored by Harry's
gentlemen do you have a bit of a stubble
growing around Harry's has got you
covered their Innovative design delivers
the same great shave you expect with
German engineer blades that Glide across
your skin and a killer new look you can
experience the latest and greatest in
the Harry's razor lineup delivers
straight to your door for just 10 at
harrys.com trash taste listen you know
me I'm the Beady boy here on trash taste
and I don't often have to get myself
clean shaven but sometimes I do and
whenever I do I always make sure to use
Harry's because their shaving is just so
clean and it makes me feel silky smooth
and oh so pretty and just for you guys
who can experience Harry's sleekest
handle yet with their craft handle
starter set for just ten dollars which
is usually valued at 17. so elevate your
shave with the latest and greatest in
Harry's razor handle lineup today get
your 17 craft handle starter set for
just 10.17 worth just ten dollars by
going to harrys.com trash taste that's
harrys.com trash taste links in the
description below for sponsoring today's
video back to the episode there's almost
a part of me that wants you to try
playing drums again why because I just
he wants to start a band yeah we're
gonna get the band back together I mean
we can do it if you like basic beats I
can teach you yeah I feel like honestly
like you know you say that you don't
have like the concept of like Rhythm and
stuff like that but I feel that's
something that can be trained I feel
it's like you know when it comes to like
musicality and stuff yeah well when it
comes to like musicality right and like
you know playing like an actual
instrument yeah um you know there's like
people who are just like I can't [__]
like I cannot imagine you playing
it's gonna sound bad an actual musical
instrument
whoa what are you saying about drums
good you know the joke of what do you
call a guy who hangs out with a bunch of
musicians no the drama oh
because because like I feel percussion
is like hey look hey I play drums that's
fine
um I feel like it's something that can
be trained because I think just like
knowing can we teach a monkey to cook
we can make it put together a carbonara
but it might not taste good yeah it's
still the skill though right like I'm
not expecting you to be the [__]
greatest drummer in the world but I
reckon when it comes to like simple you
know different stuff like a four four or
three four like you could easily do that
if I enjoyed it it would be easy but if
I don't enjoy it I suck at stuff like
this because it's like I just have no
motivation to get better at it yeah
right
um I mean it's unfortunate yeah it is
normally like that what's what's like a
one skill you want to be able to like
absolutely Master by the time you're
like I'm too old to learn anything new
I don't think there's anything I can't
I'm getting older I guess that I would
want to learn I mean yeah I'd like to be
good at cooking
that feels like an OP Strat
in general no no everything has to get
you rizz Joey good I'm not doing it
unless I get rich
we already have Partners Joey you have
nothing to prove I'm passionate about
eating food yeah and I think I would
equally be passionate about making it if
I had the time and just the space to do
I just don't have time right now and
also I don't want to that's not
something I'm interested in right now
but I can see myself being interested in
it in like 10 20 years right right when
do you okay I guess I guess since we
don't have time right now which I guess
is like the biggest factor for me
learning any new skill as well as it is
for every working adult wouldn't you
guys think you're gonna retire
when I have enough money
I mean we've seen we've seen we've seen
us like a slow Trend now about like a
lot of like well-off YouTubers who have
I guess announced their retirement like
you know PewDiePie I guess is like the
biggest he's also a dad now though he's
also a dad he also made crazy banks
that must be real that man and his son
are set for life yeah let's be real
exactly and uh like I know there was a
few others as well that announced that
was the TV was something announced that
he retired as well he also yeah
basically he basically just made crazy
bank and retirement how much crazy bank
I make see I think for me it's not only
about like do I have enough money uh to
be able to not work for the rest of my
life or you know be able to support my
children if I have any or whatever but
it's more so for me it's like you know
because I feel like retirement is that
kind of point where you're like there's
nothing I want to like turn into a
career there's nothing I want to do that
will necessarily generate money anymore
yeah and I feel for me it's like that's
a really important part about it because
it's like you can say you're retiring
right yeah you know say like oh I've
I've made enough money to support myself
for the rest of my lifetime and I've
been able to achieve this this and this
and I'm ready to put it to rest and just
like relax for the rest of my life but
if I retire and I get to the point where
I'm like yeah but there's still [__] I
want to do yeah then would you even
consider that retirement I mean I think
like you're it's not so much you're
going into retirement you're just
retiring one thing to start another
thing I mean for me I'm the kind of
person who I just need to be doing
something yeah so I I need to be doing
something you know like luckily enough
I'm in a position where I am comfortable
you know financially to be stable which
it's I guess what I thought I'd spend my
entire life working towards and like you
know Lucky in a position where I'm lucky
that I'm like okay I am stable and my
parents are stable and my family's
stable
um so I'm like if I were to like when I
reach retirement age whenever that age
is I still think I'd be doing something
yeah you know I saw like right now it's
all about it
you know right now right now it's all
about okay everything I do needs to like
have like you know it needs to be needs
to give me longevity to hopefully set
the way for the future so so I am stable
10 20 years from now so there's still
like a part of my mind where everything
I do needs to build towards a foundation
yes retirement to me means that
Foundation is set I do not need to worry
and I can focus on doing [__] that does
not mean anything in the grand Escape
yeah because like for example like my
dad went into retirement this year a few
months ago and I was like oh congrats
dad you know you finally retired you can
you know get out of this whole it sales
thing he's been doing for 30 plus years
of his life yeah and I was like so what
are you gonna do like like what's your
what's your retirement plan and he dead
ass just looks at me and he's like I
want to drive a bus
and I'm like Dad that's not retirement
you're just changing jobs at that point
like what like because I think in his
mind it was like it's not so much like
oh I'm still in the workforce or like
I'm going back to work it's just
something for him to do during the week
yeah yeah but I feel you know it's still
technically a job right being a bus
driver even if it may not necessarily be
a nine to five yeah five days a week
type of job it's still something you're
obligated to go and do and you get money
to do it right so I'm like I almost
don't count that as Retirement I I just
count that as like I think retirement
for me is when it's like okay the things
I'm going to do after all of my actual
obligatory works well that's been like
the burden of having to provide is kind
of gone yeah it's like and how you spend
your time doesn't necessarily generate
money or there's no like obligation to
to do it like you know like I'm sure
like you know I'll still be making like
YouTube videos just like casually after
I like
random attire right like you know maybe
maybe that will never stop who knows
like I could be in my 80s and I'll still
be like you know I still really want to
make this video who knows we don't know
because YouTube hasn't gone
yeah I'd like to get to my arc where
like my like I just I have a YouTube
channel where all I do is like right
boys I gotta fix the toilet yeah I'm
thinking about remodeling this room
basically basically it's basically the
content that like Felix has been doing
as of late you know to like listen to a
video where you like install the TV yeah
like he's to him he's made his money
he's good right but he's still making
those videos not because he's like I
need to put up this video to make money
to feed my family it's more so just like
I just want to do it regardless of what
it does right that's the stage I want to
read yeah I don't give a [__] what I
need to post stage yeah yeah I mean I
know you're I'm already at that point
but
but it's like for me retirement is just
like it's a combination of like do I
have enough money where everything I do
after this point may not necessarily
generate any amount of money whatsoever
but I'll still do it yeah or is it like
to the point of like there is still
something I want to do that I can turn
into this big Financial thing that will
like still support me and still be
bringing in money right and it's like
it's I feel there's like no age to that
it's just kind of at the point where you
have to just kind of self-reflect and
being like all right am I there yet like
is there have I done everything I want
to do do I have enough money in the bank
you know is My Life Stadium happy to
welcome you know my inevitable death
like when when all of the stars have
lined up that's when I feel I can be
like all right you know what I'm
comfortable to retire now you say
retirement is just the point where you
can just pursue all of the hobbies that
you'd wanted to be retirement is just
like in credit games like that's you
know it's like it's like post game it's
post game that's all retirement is it's
just like I can keep doing my [__] but I
know at the end of the day I've already
got to the credits like there's no
obligation give me a new game plus I
want a new game plus let me start it
that's called reincarnation actually
there's some things I look forward to
but I also equally feel bad that I think
like I know it doesn't matter I don't
know it doesn't matter but it doesn't
like you know it's not my life whatever
but you feel bad that a lot of like
where most people are at right now they
can't even like consider retirement
levels of saving for it and I you know
because I think we get excited and we're
like yeah what are we going to do with
when we retire and do what we're gonna
do it and I feel bad when I'm like when
you hear about people who are like man I
gotta work two jobs the thought of
retiring is not even an option right I
can't I can't ever do [__]
um and I hope that whatever happens in
the world that it gets easier for people
to be able to consider retiring and do
it because the age of retirement is
rising in every country it is it is God
especially Japan holy [__] yeah I mean
what the [__] can you can you like if
you are somebody who joins the workforce
in like the like this this like decade
can you even like consider retiring like
can you even like can you genuinely get
to the end of your career and be like ah
yes I can live off the the retirement
money like I don't think most people can
even do that now like I think that's and
also I mean you'd have to be like I'd
say like living a pretty Frugal
retirement at that stage right like
because you're only so limited to what
yeah most people can't live off yeah
like most people yeah like you know like
Japan and like America with like 401ks
and [__] like in pensions in Japan and
[__] like you know they give you options
to be able to like save up for that
retirement but you know maybe you'd be
in a position where your job isn't
paying you enough or the lifestyle
you're living is like cutting into your
uh you know you're spending too much and
stuff like that that to the point where
it just makes it more difficult to
welcome that stage right and a lot of
people don't even make it to the
retirement age yeah Japan they do yeah
I'm very good at making them uh I'm
making it to retirement age
it's getting close to 70 in some
European countries and it's like don't
make it to 70. and even if they do like
you know maybe they have a few years in
life it's like what is the what even is
retirement anymore like is retirement
even going to be a concept that is like
afforded to everyone or is it going to
be yeah something that only rich people
can can think about I mean it should be
rewarded to everyone you know to be
honest but yeah some countries it makes
it difficult yeah I mean I think it is
like one of the happiest moments in my
life at least uh was being able to give
my dad his retirement yeah yeah because
my dad had me very very late in his life
and has been like [__] Giga Chad
working his ass off to provide for me
his entire life uh especially since my
mom has had a lot of health issues in
her life as well so a lot of vets
stemmed from my dad having to you know
put the hours in uh and there was a
point when I quit for YouTube that he
did not know if he was going to be able
to retire because I'm an only child and
I don't have any brothers or sisters to
uh prop up the family it was all on me
basically so my dad went through like
massive massive [__] stress uh he
passed retirement age and he kept
working because I still like hadn't
let's say like made it then
um and you know he kept working his
office so he was waiting for you to kind
of I suppose have money to give to him
is that no no he was waiting until I was
stable enough oh he didn't want to quit
just in case hey God needs some hell
yeah yeah that makes sense okay yeah
yeah yeah because he always wants to
like I remember him telling me once that
uh at one point he was like I guess uh
he just had accepted that he would just
be working until like he passed away and
you know that that [__] hit me when I
heard it so I was like [__] I really
really really want to make this work not
just obviously for myself but because I
want to give my dad his retirement and
you know the
I I will never forget the moment where I
you know I was able to like say Hey Dad
we're financially stable and that was
the moment where I kind of like you know
said that we've paid off the mortgage
for the family house that we've been
paying off as a family for like years
and years uh and then you could like for
like I I saw like the strings of tension
just like just like completely like
Castle just everything snapped in years
hey let's go
able to make a career now I have look at
them now yeah and uh my dad just
literally just like collapsed on the
sofa and that's I hope my dad didn't
mind me telling the story but like
that's the first time I like has ever
have ever seen like my dad like shed a
tear oh and I was just like holy [__]
this is this this is what I've been
working for and now I'm like okay I'm
I'm satisfied I'm happy with my life now
I'm I'm happy I'm like monk mode
activated I am satisfied with what I've
achieved and anything else now is a
bonus and a New Journey for me I take it
back ballet doesn't get you the most
rest paying your parents retirement
that's what gets you
that's the ultimate move yeah and I'm
glad my dad can enjoy his retirement
fully now even though he was working way
harder than he should have been for a
person who's there so how is your dad
spending his retirement
learning guitar actually he is he wakes
up and he learns guitar and uh just
reading books and I'm like that's what I
want that's what I want My Head retired
oh yeah oh yeah he works oh he works so
he hasn't retired well he found no no he
doesn't work he just helps people build
stuff oh so he can't he's kind of it's
not and now he's done now he's like
remodeling the house oh he's showing me
updates if literally the house looks
like a hurricane hit it
they get an open plan
remodeling of a house here yes so yeah
he's he's doing a lot of that yeah hell
yeah I'm jealous my dad just knows how
to do stuff yeah he's like yeah there's
uh the Plumbing's broken oh yeah I know
how to fix it like how how do you know
how to fix it who told you this why I
didn't know why wasn't I taught this
yeah do you have do you ever feel like
there's life skills that people just
know and you're like where did people
learn this from yeah I mean anything to
do with like just fixing everything yeah
any skill involving any tools for so
let's fix something I'm just like how
where who taught you this for me it's
cars like anything to do with cars like
I I remember one time I had this uh I
was in like Ireland in Ireland with
Sydney
um and then you know we had a rental car
and we were just driving around uh it
broke down yeah like in the middle of
Ireland and I was like would you what
did people what'd you do what what am I
supposed to do
I'm like I I know maybe I'm supposed to
call the AAA does the AAA exist here do
we need insurance what uh what what is
the process and I because I just
realized I had just never been taught
this or I had never been taught how to
change a flat tire if you'd if I'd like
ever had a if if you ever got a flat
tire in in the middle of the road right
and I was just like I I am just so
unequipped with this life skill that
people I think people are supposed to
know I have just never experienced it
yeah well Counterpoint yes I think
that's because there's this whole level
of information that is like
stuff you should know but you don't need
to know them now because in two seconds
you can watch a YouTube video on how to
do it right like I think learning how to
change a tire yes you should know how to
do that without having to do it but I
think the reason why people don't feel
so pressed to learn it is because yeah
if it happens and let's say you have all
the gear with you you're like all right
well let's watch the Youtube video I
hope it's a good tutorial you can just
watch someone explain it yeah and you're
like okay uh and even if I knew how to
do something like change attire I think
I would just watch the video just to be
like I need to make sure yeah and I
don't [__] this off do you know how to
change the time uh I think if you gave
it to me I think I could do it
I think that's so confident I know like
I think it's the kind of thing where
like if I was with like a friend of mine
who was [__] themselves I would lie
about it and be like yeah I know what
I'm doing I'm always that guy whenever
someone is like freaking out I'm like
yeah of course I know what I'm doing and
I'm like yeah I don't know the details
but I know like the basic steps I'm like
because the thing is the thing is I had
I had to be that guy so I'm explaining
you I'm explaining Sydney's like she's
like I don't know what to do yeah I'm
actually my internal thoughts because
what happens is we break we break down
we break down the middle of the road and
Sydney's like oh what do we do and this
I I I'm like don't worry City I got it
let me check let me check what's going
on I get out the car I walk around and
I'm like it's broken I have no idea I'm
just acting like I do so Sydney doesn't
[__] panic because we're in we're in
a country we don't live in we know we
know nobody here yeah so I'm like all
right let me let me just check the
engine let me just check the water I
have no idea what that means you're
basically just staring at the engine for
20 seconds
I think I know I literally open up the
hood and I'm like when I was with my dad
he would always check the water so
that's what I'm going to do I don't know
what that really means I'm just gonna
check the water level and then I've
opened up the hood I checked the water
level and I just start googling [__]
as I went on
um yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
information that we aren't taught
because everyone just I think assumes
that oh you'll be able to figure it out
yeah like I think that stuff like that
is like that also I think that like the
fact that at least in the UK and I think
the US and whatever I think they don't
teach you anything about how to be
responsible with your money this is like
the one that always comes up right taxes
and all that the fact that we aren't
taught any of that is wild to me yeah
because I'm like that is some [__] we
all have to deal with and it [__] you
in the ass if you don't do it right you
get [__] for life you [__] up those
people I never knew how to do my taxes
or get a [__] mortgage or like any of
that [__] I wish someone taught me that
[__] yeah I I wish someone told me that
I'm flailing around like an interesting
thing you should be taught it's not like
Google like that we definitely need to
be taught like hey uh just because
credit cards say they give you money uh
there's a lot of bad things that could
happen if you [__] it up so maybe don't
use the credit card you really really
think you can handle it like that was
never taught to me I don't even know
what the difference between a credit
card on the debit card was till I was
like like 19 or 20 and I'm like oh I've
been using this for two years
if if something breaks in your house do
you know who to call yeah if my dad
I think I legit would be like hey Dad do
you think it's just like a serious thing
or a thing I should say yeah what do you
think our dad's learning from do you
think they're just making this [__] up
as because I I don't feel like then I
don't feel like they are but I like to
think that every time some [__] breaks
down in my house and I call my dad and
I'm like yeah Dad so I got this problem
what can you do he's like yeah hold on
son let me check he just opened his
phone because I've never asked my dad
who taught him yeah but all I know is
that he never taught me yeah or at least
he never taught me all the intricacies
and or everything that he knows you know
so I'm like what the [__] did he learn
it from uh
they weren't wasting their damn time
loving these liberal arts courses
yeah because you know when I you know
when I eventually have as a kid when it
whether it's a son or daughter I'm sure
they're gonna ask me about stuff right
right you're going to reach that point
in your life where your your kid's gonna
ask you about stuff uh and you're gonna
have to pretend like you know what the
[__] going on well it's like maybe the
kid will be like hey hey Dad how do you
uh install the server or something this
thing you'll be like well and he's gonna
be like how the [__] does my dad know
how to do this it's like well you just
had to learn it when you wrote that like
right I think that's just like like we
have to we have to just learn everything
about the internet and then using it I'm
sure to our whatever the kids that come
along they'll be like how the [__] do
they know all this stuff yeah you know
yeah I'm sure I'm sure how do they use
the sponsor today's video especially
it'd be funny if it's actually sponsored
how do they make a clickbait title yeah
I'm sure it's like something that we you
just grow up learning and then it seems
like crazy because they had like 40
years worth of knowledge yeah that
occasionally comes in handy right who
taught you guys how to shave I knew
you're gonna ask me I had a feeling
about this I had the sixth sense you're
gonna break okay was it okay I told
myself really my dad told me I [__] it
up for a very my dad told me and I
[__] it up was okay so your dad told
you yeah did you have to like ask him
father teach me how to shave or was
there like a was there like a day where
you're down my dad just said you your
face looks like a toothbrush let's
[__] get rid of that [__] and then he
was like he took me to the the bathroom
sink and he was like all right I'm gonna
teach you how to say
and then he was like all right bring a
roll of toilet paper because you're
probably gonna cut yourself multiple
times which I did yes and then I still
kill myself sometimes yeah and then and
then after maybe he he was with me you
know to make sure I was like doing it
correctly maybe like two or three times
and then at one point I was like yeah I
got it figured it out so like we forced
it I'll figure this [__] out God damn I
still don't think I've perfectly figured
this out because I guess like when like
I had to go to my dad to ask him I was
like Hey Dad how do you shave and he
never looked like more happy and excited
about that he's just like oh oh I got I
got a father-son moment uh he taught me
I I'm sorry to call you out call you out
for this Dad but he taught me that okay
yeah I mean you can't use shaving cream
uh soap's fine as well
and and so for my entire life I've just
like never and you guys figure this out
when I was shaving when we were like on
holiday yeah but I've never like used
shaving cream for most of my life I've
just used I've just used showers and the
fact that yeah and the fact that your
skin is like impeccable is just like not
fair hey man maybe my dad was on to
something I don't know I know you I know
in Desperate situations I've used
conditioner what yeah conditioner works
as well really it was just about having
like I think it's like a just a barrier
right you see something in the way
that's smooth and that you can still
shave through if I don't have the option
then I just don't shave I'm just like
I'll wait till I'm actually yeah but I I
look homeless if I don't sometimes I
look homeless with or without it so it
doesn't really matter for me Gamers this
episode is sponsored by Mint mobile
signing your life away to a big wireless
provider is kind of like being trapped
on a roller coaster
from hell I mean they probably even
threw in a free phone or two but now you
can't even get off of it month after
month of insane bills and unexpected
Thrills like overages and surprise fees
and look if that sounds like your
current big Wireless plan it's probably
time to get off that ride and join mint
mobile because for a limited time
Wireless plans for me mobile are just 15
a month Yes you heard that correctly
that's unlimited talk text and data for
just 15 a month listen I know better
than anyone just how much these mobile
bills absolutely stack up especially
while I was living back in Australia and
I didn't know any better about mobile
services I didn't realize I was getting
ripped off but luckily it's services
like mint mobile that help you realize
you might possibly be getting ripped off
and it's probably time to jump ship to
something better to get your new
Unlimited Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com trash that's
mintmobile.com trash cut your wireless
bill to just 15 bucks a month at
mimmobile.com trash links in the
description below thank you to me mobile
for sponsoring today's video back to the
episode I have this weird hypothetical
okay okay and this was something I was
I've been thinking about all week
because I've been playing Final Fantasy
16. yeah oh yeah right I knew you're
gonna bring that great [__] game
right but one thing I noticed while
playing Final Fantasy 16 right is that
like so to explain to you oh no you've
played the demo right I've played four
hours yeah so you know that it's like
kind of gone back to the holy medieval
setting yes right of like you know kind
of the renaissancey type of uh setting
um yeah just basically 16 hours
everyone's [__] British yeah they are
I love it but like one thing right that
I thought about while playing uh 16
right is that like when you go to like a
random Village and this is not just in
Final Fantasy this is like in any RPG
that's set in like the you know old
British setting right and you go to like
a random ass Village
and there's the village Elder right
who's like usually like pretty senile
you know like maybe like 70 80 sometimes
90 years old right and I kept thinking
to myself I'm like where did that
stereotype come from she's like a
national thing well was it an actual
yeah it was an actual thing because like
I find that hard to believe because it's
like wait why because people existed no
no that
I find that okay here's the reason why
so here's the question I had right you
are asking why is that one's old guy
that is the old guy yeah yeah because
people died but that's the thing right
it's like that's why I find it people
didn't make it to like this but that's
why that's why it's like is it even
possible to get to that point like no
like living during those times well it
was obviously right because the average
age was like [__] 40. yeah but like
people still live till like 70. pretty
often you think so yeah pretty awesome I
think you just answered your own
question because you know of course if
you live to like especially you're like
yeah especially in like you know maybe
in a village of 100 people yeah you know
odds are people would die I mean what
age what period are we talking of time
like let's say like let's go back to
like 1300s yeah I mean odds up people
weren't like what was the app can you
Google what the average age yeah yeah
because like during the Dark Ages the
average age was probably like 30.
I was like 40. okay not much but that
was mainly because of like child
mortality as well right infant mortality
was huge yeah but even like you know the
whole like fact of like you know the uh
you know medical practices weren't up to
what they are now obviously and like
obviously
it's like how you you sometimes see old
people now who will go to like seven
years old with zero like ever ever going
yeah but that must have been insane like
if you were living yeah
so if you if you were in the 1300 like
dark ages in Europe and you just went to
Orlando Village and you saw like an 80
year old that's like the equivalent to
seeing like 120 year old today yeah no
no no I would think well I mean it was
it was like rare but I mean it wasn't
that rare but it's like you know someone
who had been around who'd been in the
position where they had been in a lot of
power who was who was still alive yes
obviously they would become someone
who's respected yeah I mean at that
point everyone would be like I mean he's
[__] alive he must be doing something
why did Final Fantasy make you think of
this because I was just thinking about
it
how the [__] did the old Earth survive
[Music]
um I mean there was I I mean I don't
[__] know I don't know the exact
answer but obvious people were still
that just because the average age is is
33 doesn't mean people
don't get to no no no I I but it must
have been like incredibly rare yeah I
think you would be the village Elder
like 60 at that point yeah 55 yeah like
yeah you'd probably be the village Elder
yeah but in all video games they're
always like [__] 90 plus oh
like the modern view yeah right also
they might just look their way because
they're British you know yeah we also
like well it's also like it's like the
concept of like why do people look older
in older media like someone who's 16 in
like an 80s film looks like 25 to us
yeah but I think that is a thing yeah
yeah
watch a movie in the 80s yeah and
everyone in high school oh like sorry
well I understand not a movie sorry like
look at a yearbook of like the 80s it's
a generic yearbook people will just look
old but even movies as well like if you
go back and watch like a James Dean
movie right like that dude died when he
was like what 23 24 something like that
but you look at it and you don't think
to yourself that's a 20 year old in that
movie that's like he looks older than I
can believe he's 20 but he just looks
older to me for some reason I remember
Vsauce did a whole video yeah yeah I
just pulled up a yearbook from 1980s
America yeah look how old these people
look
this is these are high school students
see they look like in their 20s yeah
they like yeah something like older [__]
yeah it's like why is that have you ever
seen your parents pictures when they
were younger yeah it's weird
do you ever get this thing where your
parents tell you a story about some [__]
they got up to when they're like they
were kids with your age and [__] and it
just doesn't seem real and just it
almost seems like they're like reciting
a movie or something when when like I
mean it's gonna be even worse for our
kids to be like so I was just online
meme harambe right you remember right
because I pull my dick out yeah but
here's like the difference you know when
when our kids get to our age with at
least for us they're gonna have like
there's gonna be a generation of kids
that can see like video and photo proof
of all of the [__] yeah and all the
stupid [__] that their parents got up to
when they were like their age but for me
for Our Generation we have like one or
two photos that our parents took at high
school or something like that and the
rest is all anecdotal yeah so when my
aunt tells me huh you know what your mom
got up to when she was 18 let me tell
you what happened uh I just like she won
up this building it was insane about uh
some Antics she got up to that there's
one bar and I'm just like that didn't
happen that's there's no [__] there
there is no way my mother did that you
know there is no way my mother my mother
unhinged my mother getting a blackout
drunk no that that doesn't happen and
then you know you hear these stories and
it just like it almost just doesn't feel
real to you because there's no like
grounded evidence to like like prove it
in your mind see it makes sense for your
parents because I look at your parents
now and they're like so well behaved and
so like you know on point when I hear my
parents talk about their like the [__]
they got after when they were young I
look at them now and I'm like yeah I can
see that well there's gonna be on town I
mean their parents will never tell you
the really wild stuff they might have
done no of course not because they're
afraid probably they'd be like oh well
you know since I did it when I was young
then it gives you an excuse to win
you're young and I don't want myself to
do it
it's like conversation you have when
you're like 40 they're like really old
and you'll be like all right you're
going soon tell me all the [__] up
[__]
you are got four years left hops tell me
I I think I'm actually like slowly
starting to reach like that age though
because I've slowly been kind of like
being drip fed tea like here and there
from like various family members to be
like wait Auntie did what when she was
younger uh uncle was like this and yeah
it's it's slowly getting to that point
for me at least I don't think I've I
don't think I have the entire teacup I
have like a little there are a few few
little drops of tea of like crumbs yeah
a few little crumbs of tea of like
what's uh what's going on I'm just
wondering how do you think our kids are
going to react when they see this dumb
[__] we've done on YouTube and stuff
like that it's it's it must be I'm never
showing my child my YouTube channel
he's gonna find it I'm deleting that
[__] before you're the fifth is gonna
find it all right actually oh [__] yeah
it doesn't go down the accumulation of
businesses I'm gonna break them all I'm
going back to the theater that would be
hype as [__] like I started lineage my
son being full and that puts so much
pressure on the first yeah yeah he's
like all right you have to deliver so do
you sound crazy you got you got we got
four generations to figure this [__] out
yeah we should go back I think this is
more interesting
we've literally put a timer on it you're
like you better do something [__]
cool yeah first I think it would be
pretty hard though I would be pretty
hyped if I discovered like let's say
Facebook existed back in the time uh
like if I just discovered a long lost
Facebook of my mum when she was like in
University to be like oh this these are
all your drunk photos and uh all the
[__] you're getting up to okay
I think at that point you'd have to like
lock your socials up to a point until
kids are old enough to be like all right
you you have you're ready to see what
your father was with you if you are
ready to see what your father your
father was a mess
of a [__] idiot your dad was weird
when we get to the point of social media
there's like multiple Generations gone
by like I'm doing like 200 years ago
yeah I wonder what they were up to 200
years ago yeah you can just see pictures
of people getting smashed 200 years ago
at a school party it's like that's gonna
be so [__] wild you didn't just tap
into that yeah do you know anything
about like your great grandparents I
don't know [__] great cramping no no
nothing at all I've heard like just like
one or two stories but yeah it would be
super interesting just to see you get to
a point in social media where you can
see what your ancestors got up to to be
like that'd be hype as [__] that would
actually the family trees will no longer
be more Mysteries all those TV shows
about hunting down the family tree would
be so less interesting yeah we found
your great grandmother on Facebook yeah
she was kind of cringe she posted a
review of the Emoji Movie saying it not
bad so all I don't know how you came to
be yeah uh your granddad was saying some
sauce things on Twitter yeah Grandad was
in Q Anon um don't worry about that
Grandad was liking anime ludes like this
is [__] weird bro it's getting really
weird I could see uh where you get it in
your bloodline yeah
we've stammed it back do you think
there'll be services in like 100 years
that'll be like hey we can track down
your family tree of social media yeah we
can find your great great granddad's
Facebook yeah maybe unless they just
start deleting it yeah I don't know
that'll be interesting speaking of
creepy as [__] speaking it's being a
fine fancy though what uh what do you
think of it uh it's good
um definitely better than 15 that's for
sure it's most certainly a game you
would not enjoy I will enjoyed the first
two hours and then I did another stream
playing it for two hours that was
sponsored yeah it was fine but I I don't
know if I'm gonna continue yeah because
I want to play the other final fantasies
first yeah I mean I know I know you
finished the final fantasies I I think
when I went into it I like the
fast-paced combat we played eight I like
the eight yeah I like the the part of me
as much as I hate turn-based combat it's
kind of nice sometimes
really you should play 10 next I hate it
in modern games
because I feel like it's outdated right
yeah I just said in Pokemon where it
just feels like it walks
um so do you want to go back to like the
first couple of final fans yeah I'm
gonna play some of them earlier on today
everyone says six yeah I feel like six I
should play I've played some of the
other ones because everyone says in all
the Final Fantasy staff are like six is
the accumulation of the perfect Final
Fantasy it is and I'm like okay well
I'll save that then I don't want that
right away okay because then I can never
play like four or five yeah then maybe
play like yeah probably play Four first
then
they seem like it's like one like a slog
I'm not gonna lie yeah they can't be
what uh what didn't draw you in about
this Final Fantasy Final Fantasy 16. I
don't know it was on paper I'm like this
is I mean it's not that I didn't draw me
in it's just I I think that it's a lot
and I was like I also I think uh well I
don't even know what I don't even know
what I can say because I was sponsored
by them I don't always get pissed off
okay sometimes I did feel like it was
like I could put my controller down and
then I when I had to pick it back up I
was like oh [__] it's a game yeah that
was like I was like oh [__] no because
yeah because they the the producer hours
of cut scenes yeah
okay now now I understand the producer
actually said before the game came out
though that this was supposedly the most
cinematic it is messy I almost they
won't lie I almost like wish and I know
that there is an easy story mode but
like there was a version of it that was
just like a 17-hour show yeah yeah that
like didn't require you to put any input
because I actually like I found myself
getting really into the cutscenes and
then I was like oh [__] I'm gonna play
and it was fun it was great but it was
like it was like oh
I was like I'm just getting confused
with the fact that I was like oh yeah I
gotta I gotta keep playing it's an
actual game yeah it's pretty interesting
I mean it was it was very it was very
interesting because I think that it's
it's for me it I think it'll lend itself
well and history as being a great
in-between point for the series yes yeah
I think it'll lead to like 17 being like
figuring out a formula that really works
but I don't know if having that many
cutscenes is good for a game I it I'm
torn as well because even me I [__]
love the cutscenes I love voice
so it's it's so surreal just seeing like
a jrpg without like let's say the
typical anime-esque voice actors and
just saying like do you mean Xenoblade
yes yes Joey or any jrpg
yeah and the I'm hearing actual British
voice actors but there are there are
like some moments in the game where
um I like the gameplay and I really
really like the story I don't know if it
wants to be a game or a movie they made
this the cutscenes too damn good yeah
they did to the point where it's like
damn that's the that's like I'm so hyped
for the cutscene so when I go in the
gameplay yeah like I said like it's like
oh [__] okay yeah yeah I want more of
the cutscenes yeah it's it's weird
because like I really really for example
like Metal Gear Solid right the medical
solid series who
that those cut scenes were so long that
I could just put my controller down and
just zoom out for like 30 minutes I was
like I'm fine with that I'm totally fine
on that it's so weird with Final Fantasy
because the cutscenes are short enough
that I still have to pay attention about
the controller but it's long enough that
it kind of like breaks the flow of like
the gameplay I think the one issue I
have with 16 is that like I don't mind
cutscenes in my video games as long as
you're telling you know as long as it's
for a purpose and you know the narrative
is good which so far with 16 has been
great but I think my problem with 16
right now is that like the the I guess
the switching between cutscene and
playable part of the game is so like
constant yeah where it's like you know
there'd be moments where it's like okay
you get out of a you enter a village
there's a cut scene that like explains
the village and the main quest and then
you walk for 15 seconds and then another
cutscene plays and then you walk another
15 seconds and then another cutscene
plays where it's like
just give me one long
and then one long gaming session and
then I'll be good I also I I like it but
I don't know how to feel about it I like
the active law button where you can just
you'll like him you're like I don't know
what the [__] is going on in the story
let me hold down this button and it
brings up a menu that'll that you can
it'll you can move your like cursor over
it and it will tell you about what this
concept is or what this faction is you
have to be careful with that because
it's awesome stuff yeah I've heard from
people like especially near like the
last 10 of the game that part just
straight up has spoil isn't it I believe
it yeah I mean I've been trying to avoid
as much as possible I mean I think it's
a game changer because especially at the
beginning where they just introduce you
to all these all of these like countries
and people and uh characters and I'm
like I can't remember who the [__] this
is in this time skips and stuff and
you're like okay this is it's like being
thrown into Game of Thrones at like like
well I mean actually being a Thrones
Game of Thrones uh because you're just
like what the hell is happening but in
Game of Thrones of the time to go
through all of it yeah and I feel like
they may be and I remember the
storytelling is a little bit more they
introduced things a little bit better
and Final Fantasy the one thing I did
with the new one I found to struggle
with was that there was a there was too
much stuff that I was trying to keep
track of and I didn't quite understand
and that's why the active law button
felt necessary whereas I feel like it
shouldn't be necessary but a nice little
thing if I want to refresh yeah but a
lot of the time I found myself having to
do it I think the active law thing
though is definitely a good step in
direction of like explaining law without
having these like [__] Pages without
having to like go to a system and like
like the log and [__] to be like here's
like a [__] drop down menu of
everything you know where it's likely I
I I imagine that guy fox say why okay so
how do you hate yourself when well
because I was genuine like when I uh one
one of the reasons I [__] love Final
Fantasy 16 is because like the world
genuinely genuinely it's great yeah no
it's great it's [__] great and I just
wanted to be immersed so as soon as like
there's a character in like your hideout
that basically has like the is the law
keeper and that like has all of the wiki
articles and I literally just wasted I
think in like an hour and a half when
that opened up just like reading just
like reading yeah reading everything
just so I can just immerse myself in
what was going on
I I think my biggest problem with it so
far I'm about like 20 hours in at the
time recording uh there just hasn't been
a character that I have fallen in love
with yeah yeah normally in a jrpg I've
fallen in love with the cast and the the
Dynamics and you know just spending time
with these characters but so far there
just hasn't been like the characters
haven't called out to me yet I mean I
did have one but uh he didn't last long
yeah I mean without getting spoilers I
just feel like there hasn't been enough
let's say
like the main story I I feel like the
biggest weakness of Final Fantasy has
actually been so far the side quests
because side quests yeah the Side Quests
for this one are a little bit boring
yeah the side quest for me in like
especially in jrpgs is a great way to
just to just ignore the story or ignore
the main story for a bit and just flesh
out these characters hanging out
together yeah and um just uh exploring
like and expanding the world and giving
you the opportunity to learn about the
the world and the characters organically
yeah and all of the side quests so far
has just been fetch Quest and there's
been like pick up dirt yeah pick up dirt
go find this person Assassin's Creed
style yeah it is
kill five crabs and it's just like I
don't get anything more from doing these
side quests if I had not done it yeah so
it's just been like the main story for
me and the main story is great but the
main story so far has not given me
enough time with these characters enough
banter enough just natural chemistry
from each like get attached to like the
whole cast and I don't know if that's
going to change I hope it does uh but
that's like my biggest gripe with Final
Fantasy 16 how many Final Fantasy games
have you played uh I have finished zero
Final Fantasy
I've played a lot I've played a lot how
many of you played and not finished
uh seven eight
nine that's gonna be a crime that isn't
I'm crying uh hearing this yes I I think
I got I think yeah ten uh I've started
ff7 remake I haven't finished that
you have to see through it you have a
problem you realize that right finish
the goddamn game bro it's just I I don't
know are you gonna finish 16.
the biggest the biggest thing that gets
me to stop playing bro bro read like 1
000 chapters in one piece and thought
I'm done
I mean the biggest thing that has
stopped me from finishing it is
turn-based combat and uh because I just
get bored I I get bored doing turn-based
combat uh and you know especially in the
older games you have to spend a lot of
hours grinding out the turn-based combat
and then I just got I just get to a
point where I get bored and I'm like
okay I'm just gonna take a break from
the game take a break and then never
come back uh and with 16 because I
really [__] like the gameplay I I
will probably like stick through it it's
probably going to be my first fun fancy
game I finished
Fantasy games than you yeah
I mean yeah I think that's just how we
consume games differently I like to
binge I like to just destroy a game in
one go yeah like I'm done yeah and I
feel satisfied that way because before I
even get a chance to be like I'm bored
of this I'm done
um yeah I can only play like
eight hours maximum in a day before my
mind turns into like mush and I just
like I need to like step away
my mentions commercial like 14 hours in
right but then I can keep going and keep
going but it doesn't feel good for me it
depends on the game like I could there
could be some games where I'm like this
is just like a couple of hours type of
thing and then I gotta wait I gotta you
know save it for tomorrow and then this
game's like 13 Sentinels where it's like
if I spend any time away from this game
I'm going to forget everything about
this level because it's so [__]
confusing I've been into that game in
three days I need a 30-hour game and I
bet you remember nothing about it
no I remember a decent amount of it only
because like for those three days I just
only because for those three days it's
all I was [__] thinking about yeah
and it's a [__] fantastic story it's
great it's great yeah there's there's
just a lot I I needed a day to process
some of the like plot twists in that
game are you the type of [__] in
13 Sentinels that went to like the
encyclopedia section of course
that is literally like the the when you
describe doing that to me I'm like
that's like just being like you know I
just enjoy castration it's just fun okay
I can't imagine anything more [__]
unfun in my life than opening up an
encycloped I have to read ew because it
there's okay I like I'm not [__]
Okay I'm the [__] if there is a
like let's say a TV series that I really
really [__] enjoy I'm that
[__] who's like I will watch
like an hour YouTube video breaking down
the lore of [__] that happened before
the story tape like took place you know
I I love if if I'm like emotionally
invested in something I want to know as
much of the world as possible because it
just helps immerse me in the story
that's being told see I feel though that
only becomes gratifying when you make it
to the end
if you're you're so focused on finding
out like what happened to these
characters in this world in the setting
before the game took place but you'd
never see it to the end no no it's like
like okay you don't care about how a
result percentage of the like in these
games did you drop out between like 10
in 50 in what do you mean like with the
final fantastic yeah how far in were you
before
uh about 50 I think [__] it up that's
crazy that's crazy to be fair to be fair
I didn't so far drop it I just never
finished
it
was definitely no problem for me for my
my rule of thumb is if I'm not invested
in the game by around 20 30 of the way
through I don't see it to the end I feel
20 30 is like a kind of a good time to
get a good indication of like is this
game even worth finishing I don't know I
mean for me it's like hours it's like if
I if I'm not if I'm not hooked an hour
and 30 minutes in I'm done right and an
hour and 30 minutes yeah 10 of the
tutorial and like Jr no I know which is
why I always struggle because it's like
I just don't know if this is worth
investing and I'm not interested in
spending 10 hours figuring out if I
should be invested no for me this takes
me like minimum 10 hours for jail people
should be like am I invested enough in
the story yeah that's what sucked though
because when I played eight I I wouldn't
have there's no shot I would have stuck
with it if I if I spent an hour playing
it because I was like yeah this game is
I don't know anything this game ever I
think every Final Fantasy does this they
just throw a bunch of menuing at you
they're like oh this is this this is
this you're like this is a ridiculous
amount of information to ask someone to
take in uh and and just through like
explanations and it's like yeah none of
this makes [__] sense you and it's
like you guys are insane for thinking
that someone would sit 10 hours through
this to do it and people do obviously
but I'm like it's [__] that they
design a game that is just not fun for
10 hours and then then you're like okay
but now it's one is subjective yeah one
is subjective I find it fun learning new
mechanics I mean yeah I found it fun
when I got the hang of it but it's crazy
I mentioned this when we played
initially but like it's crazy that I
felt like I got the hang of it like 20
hours in that's insane did you enjoy the
story of eight yeah yeah I did yeah yeah
I liked it a lot yeah I thought it was
fun okay I thought it was okay what's
what's the general consensus of the
story of seven
the best one it's great it's great yeah
I don't think it's the best Final
Fantasy in my opinion but I think it's a
very very sorry I thought sephiroth was
like the villain in all of them
I realized he was only in seven because
but then for some reason he was just the
poster boy for Final Fantasy villains
yes because so a lot of people seven was
their first Final Fantasy because it was
the first 3D Final Fantasy yeah I was
I'm having like
characters yes with their egg beater
hands
I have this [__] ingrained in my head
and I can't stop thinking about it and
I've been thinking about it the entire
conversation we're talking about it so
this Tick Tock of someone would like
zephyruff hair like dancing and it's
like yeah when he like it kills your
entire family that's him like twerking
and like flailing his hair around like I
can't stop thinking about this that's
why that's why I'm so glad seven got the
Remake because like it is in my in my
opinion the original Seven is like close
to unplayable because it's just because
it's got a great [__] story and the
combat system is great but I just can't
get over the graphics now I I actually
I'm having huge [__] a huge [__]
trouble playing through the Remake
really yeah I think
I remember playing Final Fantasy 7 yeah
when I was a kid I don't remember [__] I
remember all I know about is that
there's like they go to like a strip
club or something yeah
yeah that's all I know about it yeah but
like I think I'm like noticing about him
because like I don't know I'm I'm
playing I'm playing for the Remake I'm
about like 10 12 hours right like it's
gonna be three games
that's [__] when when do you start
liking the characters
I'm just gonna be straight up I'm just
gonna be straight once you start liking
the characters well I feel for a lot of
people there's a Nostalgia Factor
playing the remix right like at least
for me I had it like you know when I saw
like [__] you know you know when [__]
uh you know when you first see cloud and
everything you're like is that
[__] there's that [__]
I've already spent hundreds of hours so
far Cloud's ultimately like has got as
much characterization as your general
isakai protagonist
I'm like when does cloud become
absolutely
like because I remember going into this
being like this is the classic everyone
loves this Final Fantasy yeah this is
going to be a banger I love jrpgs and
I'm just like when do when do the
characters get interesting I'm uh I'm
I'm I'm I'm waiting I'm 10 hours in
normally I'm normally I'm hooked now on
the jrpg just wait till yuffie comes out
and you'll be hooked I don't want
something about sephiroth twerking you
I'm listening to you talk and it's all
about I don't know why she's like I know
it's like a super serious story as well
I'm just imagining him twerking
yeah but several doesn't come out until
like way way way later yeah okay
generally though what what draws you to
like cloud and Tifa
um
I think because I've played all the
other final fantasies and I've played a
lot of jrpgs that were just like yeah
unlikable how did you come to jrpg man I
already have why didn't you choose that
name because it's [__] look at SEO okay
yeah I guess yeah and yeah and then I'll
get to the point where I'll just stop
playing yeah only playing Call of Duty
yeah I'm only playing first person
shooters
I think it's because like look it's in
my opinion like you know like uh cloud
and Tifa and like that whole gang is
like they're I think there are solid
cost of characters I'm not gonna say
they're the best Castle characters who
is the best cast of characters in
finalize again in a Final Fantasy game
RPGs I think I because I I come into
this I come into Final Fantasy 7 after
playing so many of my favorite jrpgs
yeah and with the critical claim that I
had I was expecting more I guess yeah
from the characters okay
one game that I've always wanted to play
it I'll say this because I'm just going
to forget if I don't say it right now
yeah uh one jab G that I've always been
interested in and everyone always talks
about is like the one of the best ever
is like Chrono Trigger yes always one of
the playbacks it looks fun okay you you
asked me what the best cost of
characters in jlpg is I probably say
chronometry like Chrono Trigger did
something like not only like what was
amazing about that game like for one one
of the best game soundtracks ever made
in my opinion uh two it's just like a
really interesting concept of not only
combat Concepts back in the day because
like back when Chrono Trigger came out
that it's not turn based anymore it's
like it's not your like average Final
Fantasy turn base it's like turn based
with a mix of real time yeah yeah right
and that was like unheard of when that
came out so that was already amazing and
then just this [__] story is I've
heard the stories
yeah it's an incredible game you should
definitely play it yeah like playing
through Final Fantasy 16 now makes me
want to play country again now yeah is
there a second one there is on like PS1
right or something uh there's chronic
Crusade oh yeah that's something which
is something different yeah like playing
blue through Final Fantasy 60 now
because I looked up the completion time
of Final Fantasy 16 and it's like you
know some people completed in like 35
hours which is let's keep cutscenes
incredible
which to me is like seems like
incredibly short foreign
at like 35. really yeah I mean I mean
name one I'll just have a look right now
six all right all right time because I
remember maybe I was just like a dumbass
kid trying to figure this [__] out but
like I remember the first time I'd be
Final Fantasy 6 35 hours
[Music]
feel a lot longer nine is 39. it feels
way longer wait look up 13 Sentinels how
long does that take it took me like
actually take time that took me 30 hours
I literally use this website for
everything cause I'm like when I'm
streaming I gotta know how long because
I I am the average gamer if not better
than the average gamer at most games
that's like what I would offer to clock
in at and then streaming kind of slows
it down so I'm normally around what
about Chrono tree
I think I beat it in like 50 60 hours
uh when focusing on the main objectives
23 hours but it's if you were trying to
do 100 42 hours can you can you search
up I might just I might have just
accidentally done 100 can you search up
Persona 5 yes because that is a long
time that's a long game that is
what a hundred hours
yeah
173 hours to 100 checks out yes I think
I think these are like what what this I
think how this website works is that
people play the game and it's like a
community thing so shout out to submit
it shout out to the people who submit I
think you're doing it you are you are
helping so much
um yeah so I think that's on average
yeah that means that if you're a fast
gamer could be 90 but if a lot of people
it could be like 100 oh first time was
Persona 5 for me and I definitely took
more than 100 yeah I took more than 100.
it's also interesting seeing how uh on
the different platforms are changes
sometimes people who played on like PC
can emulate so they can speed it up okay
what's the longest Final Fantasy game
what is the longest I feel like it's 10
yeah or maybe one of the 13 games
uh
yeah yeah I can see that that was pretty
long yeah
20 sounds great that sounds like like 20
hours to complete a main story for a
grpg that sounds so nice and digestible
it needs to get into it it fits like a
good game like I said I want to be
immersed in much possible you ask me why
I read law and why I read Wiki articles
it's because like I to me like good
World building the world should exist
even if the story isn't being told
imagining like God reading the law while
saffron's twerking ending the world
yeah that's uh that's actually uh that's
a Canon event actually
yeah like like to me like a good World
should exist even if the main story
being told didn't exist the world should
still function and to me just like the
world existing to me is almost even
sometimes more interesting than the
story being told by whatever whatever it
is you know that's how aliens feel when
they saw like World War II going on they
were like I just want to know what the
world's doing
what I have no I have no interest in
getting involved with the background law
is behind World War II I was an alien
like
that's pretty interesting actually yeah
alien's watching is being like you know
they uh they were arguing about toilet
paper before this yeah
fascinating stuff truly but in the
meantime thank you so much for watching
the podcast that is named trash taste
that we three are the hosts of Joey say
the thing hey look at these patrons and
let us know in the comments what jrpg
Connor should play what is the best
Final Fantasy let us know down below if
you're a real one you will tell us yeah
if you're a real one you'll say six no
if you're a real one you'll say the one
that I like the most which should be six
also since I know I'm gonna piss off a
lot of Final Fantasy 7 fans uh please
tell me uh tell me why is your damn game
yeah you just got to finish your final
fantasy I I need to be drawn in first
you know I need to be attached all right
but hey in the meantime why not follow
us over on our patreon to support us
directly patreon.com trash taste also
falls on Twitter send us a memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and we'll see
you guys next week as always
bye
[Music]